hallo leute willkommen zu einem neuen
video der super easy german reihe
hier stellen wir euch jede woche
deutsche werben vor
diese woche ist das verb sagen dran
los geht's präsenz ich sage du sagst er
sie es sagt wir sagen ihr sagt sie sagen
also die tasche gefällt mir schon ganz
gut aber ich sehe ein bisschen dass hier
problematisch wie sagt man dazu
bremen ein riemen janosch was sagst du
muss man immer die wahrheit sagen ja man
muss nicht immer die wahrheit sagen aber
sie bequem wenn man immer die wahrheit
sagen darf was soll ich denn sagen sagt
dass sie john und geil ist easy german
ist geil kann immer jemand sagen was
hier los ist mit harry zum ich sagte du
sagtest er sie es sagte wir sagten ihr
sagte sie sagte ja und dann sagte er das
funktioniert so nicht
nein das hat er nicht gesagt doch das
hat er gesagt die ladenbesitzer warten
dass die avocados genau richtig sind
er sagte dass wir in unseren videos
langsamer sprechen sollen
das versuchen wir auch sollte es einmal
nicht funktionieren dann könnt ihr die
geschwindigkeit bei youtube selbst
regulieren perfekt ich habe gesagt du
hast gesagt er sie es hat gesagt wir
haben gesagt ihr habt gesagt sie haben
gesagt
wer hat das gesagt hast du das gesagt
hast du das gesagt also wäre das gesagt
hast du schon mal jemandem gesagt ich
hab es niemandem erzählt wirklich das
muss auch so bleiben sagt es keinen ok
zukunft ich werde sagen 'du wirst sagen
er sie es wird sagen wir werden sagen
ihr werdet sagen sie werden sagen wir
werden es allen sagen oder ja lasst es
uns allen erzählen
die werden sich so freuen ich glaube
auch wir verlassen uns darauf dass ihr
uns immer sagen werdet was euch an
unseren videos gefällt so viel ich werde
dir jetzt meine meinung sagen deine
jacke wie toll aus ich danke
konjunktiv 2 ich würde sagen du würdest
sagen er sie es würde sagen wir würden
sagen ihr würdet sagen sie würden sagen
alina würdest du sagen dass deine
prüfungen gut liefen
ich würde sagen ja würdest du sagen dass
du gut auf deine prüfung morgen
vorbereitet bist ich würde sagen dass
ich noch ein bisschen dafür arbeiten
muss
[Musik]
mein ehemaliger lehrer würde sagen alina
auf der ist ja doch noch was geworden
ich würde sagen der tag war richtig
schön das war unser super easy german
video zu dem verb sage wenn ihr jetzt
noch weiter deutsch lernen möchtet dann
empfehlen wir euch unsere apps title
auszuprobieren
dort haben wir viele verschiedene
geschichten für euch vorbereitet mit dem
ihr schritt für schritt die deutsche
grammatik kennenlernen könnt viel spaß
dabei und bis zur nächsten woche
[Musik]
kann sie verwahrt ein problem kommen sie
vorbei danke sehr